you've written that emotion is universal
it seems that
sort of like chomsky says language is
universal there's a bunch of other stuff
like cognition consciousness seems a lot
of us have these aspects so the human
mind generates all
this and so what do you think is the
they all seem to be like echoes of the
same thing
what do you think emotion is exactly
like how deep does it run is it a
surface level thing
that we display to each other is it just
another form of language or something
deep within
i think it's it's really deep it's how
you know we started with memory i think
emotions play a really important
yeah emotions play a very important role
in how we encode memories right our our
memories are often encoded almost
indexed by emotions yeah um
yeah it it's at this core of how
you know our decision-making engine is
also heavily influenced by our emotions
so emotions is part of cognition it's
totally it's intermix into the whole
thing yes absolutely and in fact when
you take it away
people are unable to make decisions
they're really paralyzed like they can't
go about their daily or their you know
personal or professional lives so
um
it does seem like there's probably some
interesting
interweaving of emotion and
consciousness i wonder if it's possible
to have
like if they're next door neighbor
somehow or if they're actually uh
flatmates
i don't i don't
it feels like the the hard problem of
consciousness where it's some it feels
like something to experience the thing
like
red feels like red and it's you know
when you eat a mango it's sweet the
taste the the the sweetness that it
feels like something to experience that
sweetness
that
whatever generates emotions
but then like see i feel like emotion is
part of communication it's very much
about communication and then
that means it's also
deeply connected to language
but then
probably human intelligence is deeply
connected to the collective intelligence
between humans it's not just a
standalone thing so the whole thing is
really connected so
emotion is connected to language
language is connected to intelligence
and then intelligence get into
consciousness and consciousness is
collect connected to emotion the whole
thing is a
it's a it's a beautiful mess so um
um
can i comment on the emotions being a
communication mechanic because i think
there are two facets of
of of our emotional experiences
um
one is communication right like we use
emotions
for example facial expressions or other
non-verbal cues to connect with other
human beings and with other
beings in the world right
um
but even if
it's not a communication context we
still experience emotions and we still
process emotions and we still leverage
emotions to make decisions and to learn
and you know to experience life so
it isn't always just about communication
and we learned that very early on in our
in kind of our work at affectiva
one of the very first applications we
brought to market was understanding how
people respond to content right so if
they're watching this video of hours
like are they interested are they
inspired are they bored to death and so
we watched their facial expressions
and we had we weren't sure if people
would express
any emotions if they were sitting alone
like if you're in your bed at night
watching a netflix tv series would we
still see any emotions on your face and
we were surprised that yes people still
emote even if they're alone even if
you're in your car driving around you're
singing along a song and you're joyful
we'll see these expressions so it's not
just about communicating with another
person
it sometimes really isn't just about
experiencing the world
and
first of all i wonder some of that is
because we develop our intelligence
and our emotional intelligence
by communicating with other humans and
so when other humans disappear from the
picture we're still kind of a virtual
human the code still runs basically yeah
the code still runs and but you also
kind of
you're still there's like virtual humans
you don't have to think of it that way
but there's a kind of
when you like chuckle like yeah
like you're you're kind of chuckling to
a virtual human i mean
it's possible that
the the code is the has to have another
human
uh
there because if you just grow up alone
i wonder if emotion will still be there
in this visual form so i yeah i i wonder
but anyway the uh what
can you tell
from the human face about what's going
on inside so that's the problem that
effectiva first tackled which is
using
computer vision using machine learning
to try to detect stuff about the human
face as many things as possible
and convert them into a prediction of
categories of emotion anger happiness
all that kind of stuff how hard is that
problem extremely hard it's very very
hard because there is no one-to-one
mapping between
um a facial expression and your internal
state there just isn't there's this over
simplification of the problem where it's
something like if you are smiling then
you are happy if you do a brow furrow
then you're angry if you do an eyebrow
raise then you're surprised and
just think about it for a moment you
could be smiling for a whole host of
reasons
you could also be happy and not be
smiling right
you could furrow your eyebrows because
you're angry or you're
confused about something or you're
constipated yeah um
so i think this over simplistic approach
to inferring emotion from a facial
expression is really dangerous
um the solution
is to incorporate as many contextual
signals as you can right so if for
example i'm driving a car
and you can see me like nodding my head
and my eyes are closed and the blinking
rate is changing i'm probably falling
asleep on the at the wheel right it
doesn't
because you know the context you
understand what the person is doing
so i think or add additional channels
like voice or gestures or even
physiological sensors um but i think
it's very dangerous to just take this
over simplistic approach of
yeah smile equals happy
if you're able to in a high-resolution
way specify the context there's certain
things that are going to be
somewhat reliable signals
of something like drowsiness or
happiness or stuff like that i mean when
when people are watching netflix
that problem
that's a really compelling idea that you
can kind of at least in aggregate
exactly highlight like which part was
boring which part was exciting how hard
was that problem
um that was on the scale of like
difficulty i think that's some of one of
the easier problems to solve because
it's a
um
a relatively constrained environment you
have somebody sitting in front of
initially we started with like a device
in front of you like a laptop and then
we graduated to doing this on a mobile
phone which is a lot harder just because
of you know from a computer vision
perspective
the profile view of the face can be a
lot more challenging
we have to figure out lighting
conditions because usually people are
watching content
literally in their bedrooms at night
lights are dimmed
um yeah it's i mean if you're standing
it's probably going to be
the uh looking up the the nostril view
yeah and nobody looks good at
i've seen data sets from that
perspective it's like
this
this is not a good look for anyone uh or
if you're laying in bed at night right
what is it side view or something right
it's and half your face is like on a
pillow actually i don't i would love to
know have data
about
uh
like
how people watch stuff in bed at night
like do they prop their
is it a pillow
the
like i'm sure there's a lot of
interesting dynamics right
from a health and well-being perspective
right like it's like oh you're obviously
you're machine learning perspective but
yes but also yeah yeah um yeah once you
have that data you can
start making all kinds of inference
about health and stuff like that
interesting
yeah there's an interesting thing when i
was at google that we were
it's it's called active authentication
where you
you want to be able to
unlock your phone without using a
password so it would it would
face but also other stuff like the way
you take a phone out of the pocket
amazing so that kind of data to use the
multimodal
uh with machine learning to be able to
identify that it's you or likely to be
you likely not to be you that allows you
to not always have to enter the password
that was the the idea but the
funny thing about that is i just want to
tell a small anecdote is
because it was all male engineers
uh except so the there's
my boss is uh uh our boss who's still
one of my favorite humans was was a
woman uh regina dugan um oh my god i
love her yeah she's she's awesome she's
the best
um
so uh but anyway there was a there's one
female engine uh brilliant female
engineer on the team and she was the one
that actually highlighted the fact that
um women often don't have pockets right
it was like whoa that was not even
category in the code
of like wait a minute you can take the
phone out of some other place in your
pocket so anyway that's a it's a funny
thing when you're concerning people
laying in bed watching a phone you have
to consider if they're that you have to
the you know uh diversity in all its
forms depending on the problem depending
on the context yeah actually this is
like a very important i think this is
you know you probably get this all the
time like people are worried that ai's
gonna take over humanity and like
get rid of all the humans the world i'm
like actually that's not my biggest
concern my biggest concern is that we
are building bias into these systems and
then they're like deployed
at large and at scale
and before you know it you're
kind of accentuating the bias that
exists in society and
yeah i'm not you know i know people it's
very important to worry about that but i
the worry is an emergent phenomena to me
which is a very good one because i think
these systems are actually
by encoding the data that exists they're
revealing the bias in society they're
abort for teaching us what the bias is
therefore we can now improve that bias
within the system so they're almost like
putting them here to ourselves
so i'm not we have to be open to looking
at the mirror though you have to be
right open to scrutinizing the data if
you just take it as
ground truth or you don't even have to
look at the i mean yes the data is how
you fix it but then you just look at the
behavior of the system it's like you
realize holy crap this thing is kind of
racist right like why is that and then
you look at the days like oh okay and
then you start to realize that i think
that it's a much more effective way to
uh to be introspective as a society than
through sort of political discourse like
ai kind of right
um because people are easy
people are
for some reason more
productive and rigorous in criticizing
ai then they're criticizing each other
so i think this is just a nice method
for
studying society and see which way
progress
lies
anyway what we're talking about you're
watching the problem of watching netflix
in bed or elsewhere
and uh seeing which parts are exciting
which parts are boring you're saying
that's
relatively constrained because you know
you have a captive audience and you kind
of know the context and
uh one thing you said that was really
key is the accurate you're doing this in
aggregate right like we're looking at
aggregated response of people and so
when you see a peak
say a smile peak they're probably
smiling or laughing at something that's
in the content
um so that was one of the first problems
we were able to solve
and and when we see the smile peak it
doesn't mean that these people are
internally happy they're just laughing
at content so it's it's important to
you know call it for what it is um but
it's still really really useful data
i wonder how that compares to so what
like youtube and other places will use
is obviously they don't
uh have in for the most case they don't
have uh that kind of data but they have
the data of when people
um tune to now drop off and i think
that's uh
in aggregate for youtube at least a
pretty powerful signal i worry about
what that leads to
because um
looking at uh like youtubers that are
kind of really care about views and
you know tried to maximize the number of
views
i think they
when they say that the video should be
constantly interesting
which seems like a good goal i feel like
that
leads to this manic pace
of a video
like the idea that i would speak at the
current speed that i'm speaking
i don't know uh
and that every moment has to be engaging
right engaging that yeah
i think there's value to silence there's
value to the boring bits i mean all some
of the greatest movies ever some of the
greatest stories ever told me they have
their boring bits
seemingly boring bits i don't know
i i wonder about that of course it's not
that your the human face can capture
that either it's just giving an extra
signal you have to have to really
i don't know you have to really
collect
deeper long-term data about what was
meaningful to people
when they think 30 days from now what
they still remember what moved them what
changed them would help them grow
that kind of stuff you know it would be
a really i don't know if there are any
researchers out there who are doing this
type of work wouldn't it be so cool to
tie
your emotional expressions while you're
say listening to a podcast interview
and then go you know and then 30 days
later interview people and say hey what
do you remember you've watched this 30
days ago like what stuck with you and
then see if there's any there ought to
be maybe there ought to be some
correlation between these emotional
experiences
and and yeah what you
what stays with you huh uh so the the
one guy listening now on the beach in
brazil please record a video of yourself
listening to this
and send it to me and then i'll
interview you 30 days from now
it'll be statistically significant
but you know
um yeah
yeah i i think that's really fascinating
i think that's um
that kind of holds the key to uh
to a future where entertainment
or content is both entertaining and
uh i don't know um
makes you better
empowering in some way so figuring out
like
showing people stuff that entertains
them but also they're happy they watched
30 days from now because they've become
a better person because of it
well you know okay not to refund this
topic for too long but i have two
children right
and i see my role as a parent as like a
chief opportunity officer like i am
responsible for exposing them to all
sorts of things in the world and
but often i have no idea of knowing like
what's stuck like what was you know is
this actually going to be transformative
you know for them 10 years down the line
and i wish there was a way to quantify
these experiences like are they
i can tell in in the moment if they're
engaging right i can tell
but it's really hard to know if they're
going to remember them 10 years from now
or if it's going to
yeah that one is weird because it seems
like kids remember the weirdest things i
i've seen parents do incredible stuff
with their kids and they don't remember
any of that they remember some tiny
small sweet thing a parent did right
like some it took you to like this
amazing country
whatever and then there'll be like some
like stuffed toy you got or some or the
new playstation or something or some
some silly little thing so i i think
they they just like that they're we're
designed that way they want to mess with
your head
but definitely kids are very impacted by
it seems like sort of negative events so
minimizing the number of negative events
is important but not too much right
right
you can't you can't just like uh you
know there's still discipline and
challenge and all those kinds of things
so
everything adversity for sure so yeah i
mean i'm definitely when i have kids i'm
gonna drive them out into the woods okay
and then they have to survive and make
figure out how to make their way back
home like 20 miles out okay
yeah and after that we can go for ice
cream
anyway um i i'm working on this whole
parenting thing i haven't figured it out
okay
uh what were we talking about yes
effectiva the
the the the problem of emotion
uh
of emotion in texas so there's some
people maybe we can just speak to that a
little more where there there's folks
like uh lisa fellman barrett that
that challenged this idea that emotion
could be
fully detected
or even um well detected from the human
face that there's so much more to
emotion what do you think about
ideas like hers criticism like hers yeah
i actually agree with a lot of lisa's um
criticism so even even my phd work like
20 plus years ago now um
time flies when you're having fun i know
right
that was back when i did like
dynamic bayesian networks and
i said that's before deep learning that
was before deep learning yeah
yeah
i know
now you can just like
use yeah yeah it's it's all it's all all
the same architecture you can apply it
to anything yeah right
right
um but yeah but but even then i kind of
i i did not subscribe to this like
theory of basic emotions where it's just
the simplistic mapping one-to-one
mapping between facial expressions and
emotions i actually think also
we're not in in the business of trying
to identify your true emotional internal
state we just want to quantify in an
objective way what's showing on your
face because that's an important signal
it doesn't mean it's the true reflection
of your internal emotional state
um
so i think a lot of the you know i think
she's she's just
trying to kind of highlight that this is
not a simple problem and
overly simplistic solutions are going to
hurt the industry um
and and i subscribe to that and i think
multimodal is the way to go like whether
it's additional context information or
different modalities and channels of
information i think that's what we
um that's where we ought to go and i
think i mean that's a big part of what
she's advocating for as well so but
there is signal in the human face that's
there's definitely signal that's a
projection of emotion there's
that that there at least in part
is uh
the inner state is captured in some
meaningful way on the human face
i think
it can sometimes be a reflection or
um
an expression of your internal state but
sometimes it's a social signal so the so
you cannot look at the face as purely a
signal of emotion it can be a signal of
cognition and it can be a signal of a
social expression and i think
to disambiguate that we have to be
careful about it and we have to add
initial information
humans are fascinating aren't they with
the whole face thing this can mean so
many things
from humor to sarcasm to everything the
whole thing
some things we can help some things we
can't help at all in all the years of
leading effectiva
an emotional recognition company like we
talked about what have you learned about
emotion about humans and
about ai
oh big big sweeping questions yeah
that's a big sweeping question
well
i think the thing i learned the most is
that even though like we are in the
business of of
building
ai basically right
it it always goes back to the humans
right it's always about the humans um
and so for example the thing i'm most
proud of
in in building affectiva
and
yeah the most the thing i'm most proud
of on this journey
i love the technology and i'm so proud
of the solutions we've built and we've
brought to market
but i'm actually most proud of the
people we've like built and cultivated
at the company and the culture we've
created
um
you know some some of the people who've
joined affectiva this was their first
job and
while at affectiva they became american
citizens and
they bought their first house and they
found their partner and they had their
first kid right like key moments in life
that we got to be part of
and that's the thing i'm most proud of
so that's that's a great thing at a
company that works
emotionally right i mean like
celebrating humanity in general broadly
speaking yes and that's a great thing to
have in a company that works on ai
because that's not often the thing
that's celebrated an ai company so often
just raw great engineering
um just celebrating the humanity that's
great and especially from a leadership
position
um
well
what do you think about the movie her
let me ask you that before i talk
before i talk to you about because it's
not effectiva
is and was not just about emotion so i'd
love to talk to you about smart eye but
before that let me just jump into
the um the movie
uh her
do you think we'll have a deep
meaningful connection with
increasingly deep and meaningful
connections with computers
is that a compelling thing to you
something that's already happening the
thing i love them i love the movie her
by the way
but the thing i love the most about this
movie is it demonstrates how technology
can be
a conduit for positive behavior change
so i forgot the guy's name in the movie
um whatever theodore theodore
so theodore was like really depressed
right and he just didn't want to get out
of bed and he just he was just like
done with with life right
and samantha right samantha yeah
she just knew him so well she had she
was emotionally intelligent and so she
could
persuade him and motivate him to change
his behavior and she got him out and
they went to the beach together
and i think that represents the promise
of emotion ai if done well
this technology can help us live happier
lives more productive lives healthier
lives more connected lives
so um that's the part that i love about
the movie obviously it's hollywood so it
takes a twist and whatever
but but the but the key notion that
technology with emotion ai can persuade
you to be a better version of who you
are i think that's awesome
well what about the twists you don't
think
you don't think it's good for spoiler
alert that samantha starts feeling a bit
of a distance and
basically leaves
theodore
um you don't think that's a good feature
that's a that you think that's a bugger
feature
well i think what went wrong is theodore
became really attached to samantha like
i think he kind of fell in love with
that's what do you think that's wrong
i mean i think that i think she was
putting out the signal yeah this is an
intimate relationship
right there's a deep intimacy to it
right but what does what does what does
that mean what does that mean an ai
system right what does that mean right
i'm just friends
yeah
[Laughter]
well when he realized which is such a
human thing of jealousy when you were
like
was talking to like thousands of people
she's parallel dating yeah that did not
go well right
uh you know that doesn't and from a
computer perspective like that doesn't
take
anything away from what we have
it's like you getting jealous of windows
98 for being used by millions of people
but it's like it's like not liking the
alexa yeah right it's a bunch of you
know other families but i think alexa
currently is just a servant it it tells
you about the weather it's not it
doesn't do the intimate deep connection
and i think
there is something really powerful about
that
the intimacy of a connection with an ai
system
that would have to respect and play the
human game of
of jealousy of love of heartbreak and
all that kind of stuff which method does
seem to be pretty good at
i think
she this ai systems knows what it's
doing
well actually let me ask you this i
don't think she was talking to anyone
else you don't think so you think she
was just done with theodore yeah oh
she knew that this yeah and then and she
she wanted to really want to move on she
didn't have the gus to just break it off
cleanly okay
she she wanted to put in the paint no i
don't know well she could have ghosted
him yes she could have right
i'm sorry
there's our engineers oh god
uh but i think those are really i i
honestly think some of that some of it
is hollywood but some of that is
features from an engineering perspective
not not not a bug i think
i think ai systems that can leave us
now this is for more
social robotics than it is for anything
that's
useful
like i i hate it if wikipedia said you
know i need a break right now
right right like no no i need you um but
if if it's just purely uh
for for um
companionship then i think the ability
to leave is really powerful
i don't know i never thought of that so
that's so so fascinating because i've
always taken the human perspective right
um
like for example we had a jibo at home
right and my son loved it and then the
company ran out of money and so they had
to basically shut down like jibo
basically died right
and it was so interesting to me because
we have a lot of gadgets at home and a
lot of them break and
my son never cares about it right like
if
our alexa stopped working tomorrow i
don't think he'd really care but when
jibo stopped working it was traumatic
like he got really upset
and as a parent that like made me think
about this deeply right did i was i
comfortable with that i i liked the
connection they had because i think it
was a positive relationship
but i was surprised that it affected him
emotionally so much and i think there's
a broader question here right as we
build
socially and emotionally intelligent
machines
what does that mean about our
relationship with them and then more
broadly our relationship with one
another right because this machine is
going to be programmed to be
amazing at empathy by definition right
it's going to always be there for you
it's not going to get bored
um in fact there's a chatbot in china
showers shall i
it's like the number two or three
most popular app and it basically is
just a confidant and you can tell it
anything you want
and people use it for all sorts of
things they confide
in like
um
domestic violence or suicidal attempts
or you know if they have challenges at
work
i don't know what that
i don't know if i'm i don't know how i
feel about that i think about that a lot
yeah i think first of all obviously the
future in my perspective
uh second of all i think there's a lot
of trajectories that that becomes an
exciting
future but i think everyone should feel
very uncomfortable about how much they
know about the company
about
where the data is going how the data is
being collected because i think and this
is one of the lessons of social media
that i think we should demand full
control and transparency of the data on
those things plus one totally agree yeah
so like i i think it's really empowering
as long as you can walk away as long as
you can like delete the data or know how
the date it's uh opt-in or or at least
the clarity of like
what is being used for the company and i
think as ceo or like leaders are also
important about that like you need to be
able to trust the basic humanity of the
leader exactly and also that that leader
is not going to be a puppet of a larger
machine but they actually have a
significant role in defining the culture
uh and the way the company operates so
anyway so but
we should be we should definitely
scrutinize companies in that aspect but
it just
i'm personally excited about that future
but also even if you're not it's coming
so let's figure out how to do it in the
least painful yeah and the most positive
that great
you